[Music]
my name's Oliver Stevenson I'm the lead
strength and conditioning coach here
I've seen that up and we gained some
great feedback from certain players in
the squad that had used science in sport
international level at club level and
now we're set here with the partnership
and enjoying ourselves I'm dr. Rob
Jardine chief scientific officer at
science in school sampling sport the
board Aston Villa by providing them with
their nutrition needs throughout the
season and also working with their sport
scientists to provide the best nutrition
for the player match day as such is the
opportunity to top up and make sure that
they've got enough fuel to perform just
tops to recover hops you grow hops you
get stronger before a game some of the
players will use the caffeine shot about
an hour beforehand and then just before
the style of the game they might use a
caffeine gel they'll mix that caffeine
option with a carbohydrate gel caffeine
and a carbohydrate hit out to that high
incense assist
they took about in elite sport marginal
games and nutrition is the one way you
can you can gain a lot refuel at
halftime is important because
carbohydrate stores are almost depleted
so we need to ensure the players go into
that second half with that energy source
and that and that fuel raise to perform
again after a match we know that we've
got depletion of muscle glycogen which
is the main fuel in the muscle and we
also have damage to the muscle we need
to provide carbohydrate for refueling
and we need to provide protein the
repair program we as a club have been
using the rego rapid recovery plus
provided by science in sport and the
guys have given us some great feedback
on that it's very important to ensure
that all the product you take our three
advanced offenses I think the fact that
science is bought products a batch
tested is the reason why I and the
reason why this Football Club trust
trust their products
[Music]